[Applause]
thank you very much president saltas
it is such a great pleasure to be back
in essence
the most ancient capital of Europe and
one of the most breathtaking cities that
we have in Europe
former Secretary General of ban ki-moon
mayor bakuyanis
distinguished guests ladies and
gentlemen
it is a great pleasure to celebrate with
you the 10th anniversary of the Athens
democracy forum
this week
also marks another anniversary
25 centuries ago
one of the most powerful fleets in human
history appeared in the waters right in
front of Athens and Greek cities
a foreign Empire was attacking the free
cities in Greece
but it wasn't the Strait of Salamis
the Greek Alliance achieved an unlikely
Victory against the much stronger enemy
historians and Poets described that war
in very clear team terms
for the first time in history
autocracy attacked democracy
and autocracy failed
while democracy prevailed
in the words of as he lost the Greeks
tore the Yoke apart
because they were slaves to no Lord
unlike their foes the Greeks were
fighting not for the greed agreed of a
single man but for their own freedom
today once again
a democracy fights for its own Survival
against the aggression of a foreign
autocrat
Russia's attack against Ukraine
is yet another battle in a war that has
been raging for 25 centuries
the war of autocracy
against democracy
and I'm deeply convinced that democracy
will prevail
but it is also sobering to see
that the tragedies of the past keep
repeating themselves
and that too many in Europe
have underestimated the threats both
outside and inside our borders
here in Europe we saw democracy spread
across the continent decade after decade
wave after wave
when Greece Spain and Portugal freed
themselves from authoritarian rule
when the Iron Curtain came down and the
Wind of Change blew across Europe
and then
in 2003 When In This Very Hall our Union
welcomed 10 new members to the family
for more than 70 years our continent has
marched incessantly towards democracy
and many of us started to believe that
Europe and all Humanity would keep
advancing naturally towards freedom
and peaceful cooperation
we started
to take democracy for granted
today we realize that history does not
always move in a straight line
there are setbacks and comebacks
and it is every generation's task to
fight for democracy
it is our generational task to help
ukrainians
that they fight for their right to
determine their own future
it is our task
to protect the democracies from Russian
blackmail and from the interference of
autocracies
and it is our task to help strengthen
all democracies within Europe
the values that inspired the founders of
Athenian democracy should still guide us
today
the idea that power belongs to the
citizens
the idea that we are all equal before
the law
the idea that free speech is a
fundamental right
this is the immortal gift
that Greece has given to the world
yet
ancient democracy was far from perfect
or complete
only free men
could walk the road that led from this
place the Agora to the penica
where the assemblies took place
women like me
were not allowed to speak their mind
and cast their vote
the penica
is only one kilometer away from here
and yet it took thousands of years
before women finally reach it and vote
and obstacles still stand in women's way
towards full equality
today we know that democracy does not
end at The Ballot Box
democracy also means equal pay for equal
work
democracy also means equal
responsibilities and equal rights
when it comes to care and career
democracy means equal access to power
be it in politics or in business
voting rights for women we're not the
finish line
but just the new beginning towards a
perfect democracy
and this is the essence of democracy
it's always open to change it's always
seeks New Horizons
there's one concept from Aristotle
that fits perfectly to democracy
it's the idea of dinamis
of potentiality
democracy is ever changing it is a
promise that must constantly be
fulfilled
and that is what makes it stand out from
autocracy
democracy may be not perfect
but it is perfectable
so take Ukraine
when we granted Ukraine the status of
candidate to joining our Union
some objected that ukrainians democracy
may still be too young
but since the maidan protest of 2014
Ukraine's democracy has grown so much
in a few years it has reformed more than
in previous decades
it has set up anti-corruption
institutions
it has adopted first laws
to break the oligarchs grip on Ukraine's
economic political and public life
its Civil Society has conquered new
space
and holds the government to account
and the country's institutions are now
passing the ultimate stress test of work
most of this progress has been achieved
because the people of Ukraine have
Europe in their hearts and in their
minds
and the same is true for our friends in
Albania in North Macedonia and Across
the Western Balkan it is true for
Moldova and Georgia who have also asked
to join our Union
once again
the Wind of Change is blowing across our
continent
ladies and gentlemen
all democracies are constant work in
progress
including inside our Union
the European Union was built on the
promise Unity
in diversity
but this promise has yet to be achieved
in full
the path towards full equality for all
citizens is still law
racism
and anti-Semitism have not disappeared
and in parts of our Union minorities are
not always respected
lgbtiq rights continue to be violated
the rule of law and the independence of
the Judiciary are still challenged
we have seen judges stripped of the
immunity
and driven out of office without
justification
and serious concerns have been raised on
corruption
these developments are against our
values
against our treaties and against our
democracy
and as guardian of the treaty
it is the commission's obligation to act
it is up to us
to continue the work of our founders
and we have come such a long way
we are a union of half a billion people
27 countries
more than 24 different languages
countless ethnicities and culture
but one European soul
on policies there might be disagreements
and at times very severe disagreements
but the overwhelming majority of us
believes that Europe is our destiny
today I would like to speak about four
priorities we must focus on
the first of all is
the new threats
warships and soldiers are no longer the
only weapons in the hands of foreign
autocrats
they craft disinformation
they finance fake research institutes to
poison our public debates with our lives
they meddle in our elections with cash
and with cyber attacks
this is also part of their war against
democracy
and we must protect ourselves
this is why I've announced the new
defense of democracy package
we introduced legislation to screen
foreign direct investment in our
companies for security concerns
if we do that for our economy
shouldn't we do the same for our values
we need to better Shield ourselves from
align interference
my second Point are the multiple crises
our citizens demand something very
straightforward from us
that we make our democracies deliver on
the great crisis of our time
the pandemic was such a crisis
and I still remember those who were
saying
that autocracies are better equipped to
deliver results
and those who were asking to purchase
Russian and Chinese vaccine
this was just a few months ago
today
these voices have become quite
we bought vaccines together
so that all European countries big or
small low or high depths all would
receive their doses at the same time at
the same price
and it is no coincidence that this new
generation of life-saving vaccines
was developed in democracies
where freedom of science
and freedom to excel count
we reacted at the speed of light
to Russia's attack against Ukraine with
the largest sanctions package ever
with 19 billion of financial support
with military equipment
hosting more than 8 million refugees
so democracies can deliver if we are
united
we are able to find answers that are
more powerful than just the sum of 27
countries
my third point
is on New Frontiers
Putin's attack against Ukraine is an
attempt
to reverse the course of history
and to stop the long journey of
democracy
but this isn't only about Russia's
atrocious War
the number of democracies as has been
set in the world reached an all-time
high
in 2012.
but it has fallen since then
military coups have struck from Mali to
Myanmar
in Afghanistan democracy has lost
after Decades of War
millions of people across the world are
now fighting for their freedom
we see it in Iran where Brave women rise
up and demand equality and respect for
their rights
we see it in Hong Kong we're journalists
and labor right Advocates take to the
streets even though they are threatened
with prison
the Democratic Values
that were born here in Greece
have spread across continents and oceans
because all people aspire to Freedom
even especially in countries where
democracy has not flourished yet
there can be no doubt
the desire to determine the course of
your life
and to be the master of your own future
Burns in every human soul
and I want our Union to stand at the
side of every country that longs for
freedom
and every young democracy that strives
for more
in Europe and Beyond
this means
first and foremost to support Ukraine
with economic political and Military
means but there is more
autocracies are using more subtle means
to curtail the sovereignty of other
nations
Chinese investment for instance is
pushing several low-income countries on
the brink of default
and Russian gas and oil always comes at
the expense of national sovereignty and
Independence
this is
where global gateway comes into play
global gateway is our new European
program to address the global investment
gaps for infrastructure from Energy
Systems to digitalization
global gateway
is driven by democratic values
we offer Investments that are
sustainable
for countries finances
and respect its sovereignty
we offer digital Investments that
protect individual rights
in a digital world
Investments
that Advance the rights of workers and
local communities
it is a way of promoting our Democratic
Values at all corners of the world
and finally
let us never forget
that our democracies belong to Future
geminarations
for too long Humanity has behaved like
there was no tomorrow
instead of preserving
at nurturing the world around us
we devoted
piece by peace
at the expense of future Generations
climate change is the Colossal burden we
are slamming on our children's future
if we want young people to have faith in
our democracies
we must finally put young people at the
heart of everything we do and this is
why I have proposed to enshrine
solidarity between Generations in the
fundamental treaties of the European
Union
every action
every action that our Union takes
should be inspired by a simple principle
that we should do no harm to our
children's future
and we should have the world a better
place
for the Next Generation
this
is the essence in the long journey of
democracy
it is about restoring confidence in our
future
and not only announcing with words to
new generations that tomorrow will be
better than today
but proving it by Deeds
ladies and gentlemen
democracy is a promise
it is the promise
that people can be masters of their own
future
that we can determine the course of our
countries
and change course when necessary
this is the greatest strength of
democracy
what makes it more just and more
successful than any other form of
government
autocracies always look backwards
their assistance
built so that the powerful can cling on
to power
and so that people are stuck
in a never-ending past
when I look at the challenges of today
Russia's warned Ukraine
the blackmail through energy
the pressures of our way of life
then I know that we are all being tested
today whether we defend democracy
whether we are steadfest united
and determined each and every one of us
is part of our resilience
it's up to us to protect our future
it is up to us to make democracy prevail
it is up to us to stand in unity and
therefore long-live Europe and many
thanks for your attention
[Applause]
[Music]